Quelque part en Europe,
il existe un endroit
où la fin annoncée
des réserves de pétrole
ne fait plus peur.
Un endroit où
produire de l'énergie sans or noir
est déjà une réalité.
Nous sommes
au sud de l'Espagne.
À 20 kilomètres de Séville,
au bout de cette petite route
perdue dans la campagne andalouse,
une surprise
de taille nous attend.
L'endroit ressemble
à un décor de science-fiction.
Autour de nous, des dizaines,
des centaines de miroirs
plantés au milieu de nulle part.
Ils sont là pour capter
une énergie gratuite,
inépuisable, écologique,
celle du soleil.
Chacun de ces miroirs
alignés sur un kilomètre carré
renvoie l'énergie pour la concentrer
au sommet de cette tour.
Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
Comment ça va ?
Ça va, merci.
-Il fait très chaud ici.
Il fait chaud.
Valerio Fernandez est l'ingénieur
qui a conçu toute cette installation.
Ici, il produit de l'électricité
sans une goutte de pétrole.
On dirait
un film de science-fiction.
On le dirait,
mais c'est tout à fait réel.
Cela fait quatre ans
que je produis de l'électricité
dans cette installation.
Tout le processus se passe
au sommet de la tour.
Les rayons renvoyés
par les miroirs sont concentrés
dans une sorte de four géant.
Il y règne une chaleur infernale,
500 degrés.
Au milieu se trouve
un réseau de tuyaux où circule de l'eau.
Au contact
des rayons du soleil,
elle se transforme en vapeur
qui va venir alimenter une turbine
située au pied de la tour.
Elle va faire tourner des hélices
qui vont à leur tour
entraîner un générateur
pour fabriquer du courant,
comme c'est le cas
dans une centrale classique.
Sauf qu'ici, on utilise du soleil
à la place des énergies fossiles.
Pourquoi est-il si important
de disposer de ce genre d'alternative ?
Il y a de nombreuses raisons.
L'une d'entre elles est
qu'il n'y aura plus de pétrole un jour.
Nous devons penser
à d'autres façons d'obtenir de l'énergie,
de sources solaires ou d'autres sources,
car si nous continuons à consommer
des ressources non renouvelables,
nous allons avoir un problème
dans le futur,
si nous ne prenons pas les devants.
Le soleil pourrait être une réponse.
Bien sûr.
Cette électricité fabriquée
avec les rayons du soleil
est ensuite injectée
sur le réseau et envoyée
jusque dans
la capitale de l'Andalousie.
À 20 kilomètres de là,
Séville et ses habitants
consomment cette énergie pour vivre.
Ils l'utilisent pour
les transports urbains comme le tramway,
pour les feux de signalisation,
pour l'éclairage public ou tout simplement
pour la vie de tous les jours.
Aujourd'hui, la moitié
des 700.000 habitants
profitent déjà
de cette électricité solaire.
Demain, c'est toute la cité
qui pourrait fonctionner
avec cette énergie propre.
Derrière cette révolution,
il y a l'espoir
qu'un jour cette ressource naturelle
puisse remplacer le produit
qui fournit aujourd'hui
de l'énergie à toute la planète.
Un produit que nous allons chercher
au cœur de la terre,
qui bientôt n'existera plus.
Il est brun,
il est visqueux.
Il a mis 100 millions d'années
à se former.
On le surnomme l'or noir.
Le pétrole et le moteur
de notre monde moderne.
Avec lui se développent
aux quatre coins de la planète
l'automobile, l'aviation
et toutes sortes de transports
toujours plus rapides.
Avec lui, nos habitations
sont mieux chauffées, mieux éclairées.
Avec lui encore émergent
des milliers de produits
devenus indispensables
à notre vie quotidienne,
plastiques, textiles,
ordinateurs ou médicaments.
Depuis 150 ans,
nous vivons dans l'ère du pétrole.
Chaque jour,
nous en consommons 14 milliards de litres.
Il est devenu un enjeu fondamental
pour l'humanité.
Le pétrole devient
de plus en plus rare.
Il est aussi
de plus en plus cher.
Il contribue
au réchauffement climatique.
Tout cela n'est pas viable à long terme.
Voilà pourquoi nous sommes partis
aux quatre coins du monde
pour comprendre comment
notre dépendance au pétrole
nous oblige désormais
à aller le chercher toujours plus loin,
à aller creuser
toujours plus profondément.
Voyez là, on creuse à trois kilomètres
de profondeur pour trouver du pétrole.
Cette soif de pétrole
n'est pas sans risque pour la nature.
Elle provoque
des marées noires gigantesques,
des émissions de gaz polluants,
une menace pour notre environnement
et pour notre vie.
Il va y avoir prochainement
80 puits supplémentaires autour du lac.
Je suis inquiète
de la contamination de l'eau
que pourrait causer le pétrole ici.
Cette quête effrénée
a aussi une autre conséquence.
Un peu partout sur la planète,
les gisements s'épuisent.
D'ici 15 ans,
on va commencer à manquer de pétrole.
Nous avons cherché à savoir
quelles alternatives existent aujourd'hui.
Quelles solutions écologiques
sont en œuvre pour réussir à se déplacer,
à se chauffer, à s'éclairer,
bref à vivre sans pétrole.
Ce qui est formidable
quand on vit dans ce quartier,
c'est de pouvoir recycler nos poubelles
pour en faire une source d'énergie.
Un voyage qui nous a conduit
là où certains ont trouvé
les matériaux et les technologies
de demain qui permettront un jour
de se passer complètement de l'or noir.
Dans cette eau ?
Oui.
Il y a ce qui va faire marcher
les voitures de demain.
Oui, c'est ça en quelque sorte,
Des déserts du Chili
jusqu'aux grandes plaines des États-Unis,
des hauts plateaux boliviens
jusqu'au quartier écolo de Stockholm.
Nous avons enquêté pour répondre
à une question qui nous concerne tous.
Comment est-il possible
dès aujourd'hui de vivre sans pétrole ?
Notre enquête sur le pétrole
commence à moins d'une heure de Paris,
dans les immenses plaines
de Seine et Marne.
Ici, on fait principalement
pousser des céréales.
Ce qui intéresse Emmanuel Mousset
n'a rien à voir avec l'agriculture.
Ce géologue dirige une société américaine
de prospection pétrolière.
Du pétrole, cela peut paraître surprenant,
il y en a dans notre sous-sol,
ici en France.
Vous voyez qu'on a
une couleur un peu brune,
Ça, c'est un mélange d'eau et de pétrole.
On voit le pétrole qui surnage,
c'est un pétrole de bonne qualité.
Un pétrole de bonne qualité
et facilement accessible.
Ce pétrole,
nous en avons très peu en France,
à peine 1 %
de nos besoins annuels.
Le reste, tout le reste,
nous l'achetons à l'étranger.
Il provient principalement
des gisements du Moyen-Orient,
premier fournisseur mondial.
Une facture énorme
qui ne cesse de flamber.
Les prix de l'essence
sont devenus une obsession
pour la plupart des français
quand ils vont faire le plein.
Dans ma voiture,
avant je mettais 45 euros d'essence.
Maintenant je mets 55 euros.
Ça fait 10 euros en plus
en six mois de temps.
Notre pouvoir d'achat
ne cesse de baisser.
On se demande si un jour
on pourra continuer à rouler.
1,50 euro le litre en moyenne,
c'est presque deux fois
plus cher qu'il y a dix ans.
La tendance ne fait que monter
et n'est pas prête de s'arrêter,
comme l'annonçait
il y a peu le patron de Total.
Il n'y va pas par quatre chemins,
le patron de Total.
Ce matin,
l'essence est à 2 euros le litre.
On y va tout droit,
ça ne fait aucun doute.
La vraie question, c'est quand ?
2 euros le litre.
Pour limiter cette hausse des prix,
il y aurait peut-être une solution :
découvrir de nouveaux gisements
chez nous en France.
C'est justement ce que
certaines sociétés pétrolières
pensent avoir trouvé ici
sous les champs de Seine et Marne.
Un autre gisement gigantesque,
bien plus profond
que celui exploité actuellement.
Un gisement démesuré
qui fait rêver Emmanuel Mousset.
On peut penser
qu'il y a quelques milliards de barils
peut-être à récupérer sous nos pieds
dans le bassin de Paris,
dans ces réservoirs-là.
Incroyable !
Jusqu'à 100 milliards de barils
selon les experts,
dormiraient ainsi
dans les sous-sols de l'Île de France.
Un pétrole d'un genre nouveau
qu'il faut aller chercher
beaucoup plus loin sous la surface.
Un pétrole que l'on ne savait pas
exploiter jusqu'à maintenant,
puisqu'il est contenu
dans une roche très dure, le schiste.
C'est une roche
qui contient du pétrole et du gaz.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le pétrole
et le gaz de schiste.
Il y en aurait
des quantités considérables
aux quatre coins de la planète.
En Europe par exemple,
on en trouve notamment en Allemagne,
en Pologne,
en Roumanie, en Hongrie.
Rien qu'en France,
ce nouveau pétrole de schiste à lui seul
permettrait de multiplier par dix
notre production annuelle.
Contre toute attente,
ces nouvelles sources d'énergie
suscitent la polémique
un peu partout dans le monde.
Non au gaz de schiste.
Ici au Canada,
ou bien en France,
la mobilisation est générale.
Élus et habitants
dénoncent un risque environnemental.
Ce qui a provoqué
cette levée de boucliers,
c'est un documentaire
américain spectaculaire.
Gasland, un film sur les méthodes
d'extraction du gaz de schiste
aux États-Unis
et une image qui a fait le tour du monde.
De l'eau du robinet qui prend feu.
Pour le réalisateur du film,
cela signifierait
que les compagnies américaines
polluent les réserves d'eau potable
en voulant extraire le gaz de schiste.
Qu'en est-il pour son cousin,
le pétrole de schiste ?
Cette réserve colossale qui dormirait
sous les champs de Seine et Marne
est-il aussi dangereux à récupérer
que le gaz de schiste ?
Ou bien peut-il être chez nous en France,
le gisement providentiel
qui pourrait faire baisser
le prix de notre essence ?
Nous partons vers un lieu
qui détient les réponses
à toutes ces questions.
L'État du Nord Dakota aux États-Unis.
Le premier pays au monde
à avoir exploité le pétrole de schiste.
Le Dakota du Nord est immense,
grand comme un tiers de la France.
À perte de vue, des champs agricoles
dédiés aux cultures de céréales.
On pourrait se croire
dans les paysages de Seine et Marne.
La différence, nous la découvrons
en arrivant dans la capitale de l'État,
à Bismarck.
Une ville qui ressemble
aux bourgades de l'Amérique profonde.
Depuis quelques années,
le Nord Dakota vit une révolution.
Cet État très pauvre est devenu
l'un des plus riches d'Amérique.
Puisque dans les champs,
voilà ce qui pousse.
Ce sont les puits de pétrole.
Il y en a trois nouveaux chaque jour
qui apparaissent dans le paysage.
On en croise partout
dans le Nord Dakota.
Depuis quelques années,
ils font la fortune
de milliers d'habitants.
Parmi eux, Larry Lee State,
un ancien enseignant.
Ses revenus aujourd'hui,
ne proviennent pas de sa retraite,
mais d'une source beaucoup plus généreuse
qui se trouve sur ses terres.
C'est un autre ?
-Oui.
Ça produit du pétrole ?
Même quand ça ne bouge pas.
Il y a tellement de pression
là en dessous.
Quand on creuse la première fois,
pas besoin de pomper
les deux
ou trois premières années.
Si c'est un bon puits,
le pétrole sort tout seul.
Regardez ces flammes des torchères.
Il y a tellement de pression
qu'on n'a même pas besoin de pomper.
C'est grâce à ce puits
et trois autres comme celui-ci
que Larry est devenu millionnaire.
Une histoire qui ressemble à celle
de bien d'autres familles dans la région.
À Stanley, petite bourgade
de 5000 habitants,
ils sont plusieurs dizaines
à avoir loué leurs terres
aux compagnies de forage.
Ici, cela n'a pas vraiment modifié
le train de vie
de ces nouvelles fortunes du pétrole.
Pour Larry et sa femme Violette,
tout a commencé il y a moins de dix ans
lorsqu'une société pétrolière
les a convoqués et leur a montré une carte
avec la localisation des futurs puits.
On a vu sur leur carte tous les points
qui représentaient des projets de puits.
En plein sur nos terres.
Là, on était tout excité.
Combien ?
-Quatre.
Quatre.
On s'est dit,
c'est sur nos terrains, les nôtres.
C'est là où on a réalisé
ce qui se passait.
Le pétrole fût pour eux
comme un ticket de loto gagnant.
Du jour au lendemain.
leurs revenus ont été multipliés par 30.
Combien pensez-vous toucher
en moyenne par jour ?
Je dirais un peu
plus de 1 000 dollars par jour.
1 000 dollars par jour ?
Oui, je pense.
-Pas mal.
Oui, c'est mieux que de travailler.
Soit 30 000 dollars par mois
sans travailler, pendant un demi-siècle.
D'après nos estimations, Larry et Violette
devraient toucher au total
jusqu'à 20 millions de dollars.
Le pétrole de schiste est en train
de bouleverser toute une région.
Il a non seulement créé des millionnaires,
mais a aussi généré
un gigantesque boom économique.
Le Dakota du Nord est aujourd'hui
l'État américain
où le chômage n'existe plus.
Des travailleurs
accourent de tout le pays.
C'est la ruée vers l'or noir.
Pour se loger,
ils sont obligés de s'installer
dans des habitations improvisées,
comme cet immense champ de mobilhome,
puisque la région
est débordée par son succès.
Nous n'allons pas tarder
à en faire les frais lors de notre voyage.
Pour notre équipe,
impossible de dormir dans un hôtel.
Ils sont tous complets,
occupés par les travailleurs du pétrole.
Nous sommes donc obligés
de nous rabattre sur ce camping-car.
Un camping-car avec
tout le confort à l'américaine.
C'est notre chambre d'hôtel.
Ça, c'est votre chambre
d'hôtel à roulettes.
Ça, c'est le lit.
Là, il y en a un autre
et un autre au fond.
Ça, c'est un lit ?
Je vais vous montrer.
Quand il n'y a pas assez de places,
il suffit de pousser les murs.
C'est d'ailleurs
ce que tout le monde essaie de faire ici.
C'est le grand problème en ce moment.
Il y a plus de 3000 personnes
qui recherchent un logement.
À cause de l'industrie pétrolière ?
Oui, à cause de tous ces travailleurs
qui cherchent à se loger.
Il y a deux hôtels qui viennent juste
d'ouvrir dans le coin.
Les compagnies pétrolières
les ont déjà louées pour deux ans.
Aucune chambre libre
pendant deux ans ?
Exactement.
C'est incroyable.
Nous héritons d'un véhicule
aussi grand qu'un bus parisien,
pas très pratique à manœuvrer.
C'est énorme.
Des hôtels complets,
du boulot pour tout le monde,
des nouveaux millionnaires.
Voilà ce qui nous frappe ici.
Une situation dont nous aussi en France,
nous pourrions rêver
avec nos nouveaux gisements.
Derrière ce tableau idéal,
nous voulons comprendre
dans quelles conditions
le pétrole de schiste est exploité ici,
s'il y a un impact sur l'environnement.
Craig Lawson
est un des pionniers de cette industrie.
À 53 ans, il est l'un
des plus gros producteurs
d'or noir du Dakota.
Il possède une centaine de puits.
Ce jour-là, une étape cruciale,
celle du forage.
Pour réussir le forage,
il faut tourner le tuyau dans ce sens.
C'est la machine à eau qui le permet.
Pour extraire
ce pétrole de schiste,
impossible d'utiliser
les mêmes méthodes de forage
que pour le pétrole classique.
Voilà comment ça se passe.
Pour un gisement classique
comme au Moyen-Orient,
il suffit de creuser verticalement
sur quelques centaines de mètres
pour atteindre les couches de roches
qui contiennent le pétrole.
Il sera ensuite pompé vers la surface.
Ici, les équipes de Craig Lawson
doivent utiliser
une toute autre technique,
une technique plus compliquée,
bien plus risquée
pour l'environnement.
À ce jour,
c'est la seule méthode maîtrisée
pour récupérer le pétrole de schiste
comme celui que nous avons en France.
D'abord, il faut forer à la verticale,
beaucoup plus profondément à 3000 mètres,
puis à l'horizontale
sur plusieurs kilomètres de longueur.
Ensuite, on injecte un liquide
que l'on envoie
dans le puits
à très haute pression.
L'objectif étant de fissurer
cette roche très compacte
sur plusieurs centaines de mètres
pour en libérer les millions
de gouttes de pétrole
qui y sont coincés.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
la fracturation hydraulique.
Cette technique présente de graves
inconvénients pour l'environnement.
C'est ce que nous révèle notre enquête.
Nous partons là où se déroule
tout ce processus de fracturation,
juste à côté
du puits de forage principal.
La première chose que nous remarquons,
c'est cette file interminable
de camions citernes.
Sur le site,
la logistique est considérable.
Voici le puits à partir duquel
on va injecter tout le liquide
pour fissurer la roche.
Une mixture dont Jolly,
le responsable du chantier,
connaît la recette par cœur.
Je peux vous emmener là-bas
pour vous expliquer, ça sera mieux.
Parmi les ingrédients principaux,
il faut un cocktail de produits chimiques
hautement toxiques qui se trouvent stockés
dans ces réservoirs en plastique.
Les étiquettes sont sans équivoque.
L'étiquette rouge signifie
que le contenu est très inflammable.
Vous ne devez pas approcher
la moindre flamme.
Celui à l'étiquette noire est un corrosif.
Ça veut dire que
si ma main touche ce produit...
C'est corrosif pour les métaux
et pour la chair humaine.
Ça veut dire que
je n'aurai plus de mains.
Oui, ce n'est vraiment pas bon.
Ça vous brûlerai.
Jolly utilise huit produits chimiques
différents injectés
grâce à un système de pompe.
Le principal composant du cocktail
est stocké dans ces réservoirs jaunes.
Il s'agit de l'eau.
Le problème, c'est qu'il faut
des quantités astronomiques d'eau
pour que l'opération fonctionne.
C'est dans ce camion
transformé en quartier général high-tech
que nous allons
nous en rendre compte.
Bonjour.
Joëlle est le responsable
de la fracturation hydraulique.
Avec ses ingénieurs,
ils surveillent la consommation d'eau.
Pour l'évaluer,
il faut sortir la calculatrice
puisque même le chef
se perd dans ces chiffres démesurés.
Ça fait 50 000 barils fois 42 et non
55 000 divisés par 110.
Le résultat est spectaculaire.
Ça fait 8 millions de litres
pour ce puits.
8 millions de litres d'eau ?
C'est ça,
8 millions de litres d'eau.
C'est l'équivalent de trois piscines
olympiques pour un seul puits.
Il y a dans la région
2600 forages comme celui-ci.
Honnêtement, si on additionne
toutes les fracturations hydrauliques
et le besoin de creuser plus
pour répondre à la demande,
inévitablement vous allez
être à court d'eau.
Si vous faites le calcul.
Franchement on n'utilise pas
beaucoup d'eau.
Non, franchement.
Il ne peut pas comprendre,
il n'est pas du métier.
Ça fait 8 millions de litres d'eau.
Il n'y a pas de quoi s'inquiéter ?
On ne peut pas revenir au charbon.
C'est quoi la solution ?
Il faut continuer à creuser.
On creuse jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve
de quoi remplacer le pétrole.
8 millions de litres d'eau,
100 000 litres de produits chimiques
par fracturation hydraulique.
Voilà donc le premier impact
de cette technique sur l'environnement.
Si nous voulions extraire
du pétrole de schiste en France,
nous serions obligés
d'utiliser cette méthode.
Notre enquête sur cette technique
va nous conduire de surprises en surprises
sur les dégâts qu'elle occasionne.
Après la fracturation,
80 % du cocktail injecté remonte du puits.
C'est un liquide hautement toxique
dont on ne sait pas quoi faire.
Les compagnies le stockent quelques mois
dans ces bassins de rétention.
Vu du ciel,
voilà ce que ça donne.
Des bassins d'eaux polluées,
il y en aurait six nouveaux
créés chaque jour.
Ils sont censés être étanches,
mais on voit bien
que certains présentent des fuites.
Ici, les eaux toxiques polluent le sol
à quelques mètres d'un champ agricole.
Plus grave,
les oiseaux qui se posent sur ces bassins
ont peu de chance de survie.
Les résidus de pétrole
alourdissent leurs ailes,
les empêchant de décoller.
Ils vont mourir noyés.
À entendre les industriels
comme Craig Lawson,
ces retenus d'eau
ne poseraient aucun problème.
C'est tapissé avec
une bâche en plastique très épaisse.
Il n'y a aucune infiltration possible
dans la terre.
Puis on met des petits drapeaux
pour effrayer les oiseaux,
pour les empêcher de venir ici.
Par ailleurs, est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il pourrait y avoir des émanations ?
Non, parce que si l'eau s'évapore,
les produits chimiques resteront au fond.
Les produits chimiques
ne peuvent pas s'évaporer avec l'eau ?
Je ne pense pas.
Pour Craig Lawson,
il n'y a donc pas de problème.
Si demain le pétrole de schiste
devait être extrait en France,
quels risques
les habitants voisins de ces exploitations
pourraient-ils courir ?
Dans le Dakota, certains qui vivent
à proximité des puits de pétrole,
ont un avis tranché sur la question.
Il existe une ferme
qui a depuis peu un nouveau voisin.
La maison des Jorgensen
se trouve à 600 mètres à peine
d'un puits de pétrole flambant neuf.
C'est ici que vit Brenda,
une femme d'agriculteur.
Un beau matin, au cours d'une promenade,
elle s'est rendue compte
que son nouveau voisin
pouvait avoir des effets sur sa santé.
Je suis allée voir ma fille
qui vit à côté.
Quand je suis rentrée,
mes yeux me piquaient et me brûlaient.
Puis pendant deux ou trois heures,
quand j'essayais de parler,
j'avais la gorge qui me grattait,
toute sèche, impossible de parler.
Nous emmenons Brenda sur le site,
pour voir de plus près
ce qui perturbe sa vie
depuis quelques temps.
En effet, à peine sortie de voiture,
nous sommes saisis
par une odeur très forte
de produits chimiques.
Je n'aime pas l'odeur.
C'est ici que ça sent le gaz.
C'est le gaz qui vient de là ?
-Oui.
Comme Brenda,
ils sont des centaines dans la région
à vivre près
de ces installations pétrolières
et à redouter
des effets nocifs sur leur santé.
Ces émanations chimiques
constituent-elles une réelle menace
pour tous ceux qui habitent
près de ces bassins comme ici au Dakota,
ou peut-être demain en France ?
Pour en avoir le cœur net,
nous partons à 1000 kilomètres de là.
Direction, Denver dans le Colorado.
Notre rendez-vous
a lieu à l'École de médecine
de l'université du Colorado.
Voici Daniel Turtelboom.
Il est professeur de toxicologie.
Sa spécialité,
c'est l'impact des rejets industriels
sur la santé des citoyens.
Nous lui avons confié des résultats
d'analyse d'un bassin similaire
à celui de Brenda
et voici ce que contiennent
ces eaux issues de la fracturation.
Mercure, baryum, arsenic, cadmium,
chrome, plomb, sélénium, argent.
Au total, huit composants chimiques.
Voici comment ces substances
peuvent s'éparpiller
bien au-delà des bassins de rétention.
Ça commence comme un conte pour enfant
et ça peut finir en tragédie.
En hiver, en majorité,
tout cela reste dans l'eau
puisque l'eau est gelée.
Quand ça se réchauffe au printemps,
des particules volatiles s'évaporent.
Avec le vent, ça va aller
là où les gens habitent.
Si ce bassin est à quelques
centaines de mètres d'une habitation,
il pourrait y avoir
une dose relativement importante
de ces particules volatiles
qui touchent les habitants.
Quels sont les risques
pour la santé des riverains
d'un bassin d'eau toxique
comme celui de Brenda ?
La réponse est peu rassurante.
Je dirais que les trois
plus grands risques sont en premier
s'il y a du plomb
et des hydrocarbures volatils
sur une longue durée,
il pourrait y avoir
des dégâts neurologiques.
Ensuite, il peut y avoir
des problèmes sur le foie,
en troisième lieu,
des risques de cancer
à cause de certains éléments,
comme par exemple, dans ce cas-là,
il y a une teneur élevée en chrome
dans ces échantillons.
Le chrome, un produit
qui a déjà fait scandale,
qui est à l'origine d'une affaire
connue dans le monde entier.
L'affaire Erin Brockovich.
Qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour vous ?
Hollywood en a fait un film
avec Julia Roberts.
Je suis venue voir
des registres de l'eau.
L'affaire Brockovich, c'est l'histoire
d'une employée d'un cabinet d'avocats
qui découvre qu'à cause
d'une entreprise industrielle,
l'eau potable d'une ville de Californie
était contaminée par du chrome.
La compagnie Pacific Gas and Electric
est sommée d'assainir
les rejets de déchets
contenant du chrome hexavalent.
Le chrome hexavalent,
l'objet du scandale.
La véritable Erin Brockovich
va gagner un procès retentissant
qui coûtera
une fortune aux industriels.
Ce Chrome Hexavalent
contenu dans l'eau potable
des habitants de l'affaire Brockovich
est-il comparable à celui retrouvé
dans les bassins
de rétention du Dakota ?
Ce produit chimique,
notre toxicologue le connaît bien.
Il l'a étudié pendant des mois.
Le chrome hexavalent est le même produit
que celui dans l'affaire Brockovich.
Si vous vous souvenez
de cette affaire en Californie,
j'étais le toxicologue dans cette affaire.
La plupart de ces composés chimiques
ont un effet
au bout de 10
à 15 ans au minimum.
Le problème, c'est que tous les dégâts
devraient apparaître
après la fermeture de ces bassins,
après que le responsable
de la contamination soit parti.
Le problème demeurera
pour les gens qui ont été exposés.
Des effets sur la santé
qui ne se feront sentir qu'avec le temps.
Voilà ce que les riverains
de ces installations risquent de vivre.
Des craintes qui expliquent
la mobilisation des citoyens
contre le pétrole de schiste en France
et au Canada notamment.
Face à cette menace,
les compagnies pétrolières affirment
avoir trouvé la solution
pour se débarrasser des eaux toxiques
qui stagnent dans les bassins.
Il ne s'agit pas de recyclage,
mais d'un gigantesque camouflage.
Cela se passe
dans une station comme celle-ci.
Les eaux toxiques sont injectées
sous terre à un kilomètre de profondeur
sans aucune certitude
sur les conséquences à long terme
pour l'environnement.
Devant les risques écologiques
générés par cette industrie,
que font les autorités ?
Pour obtenir des réponses,
nous nous rendons
au ministère de l'industrie locale.
La commission de surveillance Pétrole
et gaz du Nord Dakota.
Lean Elms est
le Monsieur pétrole de l'État.
C'est lui qui supervise
toute l'activité pétrolière.
Il y a déjà 2600 puits au Nord Dakota,
un nombre qui devrait être multiplié
par dix d'ici dix ans.
Une chose est sûre, un tel développement
aura un impact écologique très important.
À ce propos,
ce que va dire devant nos caméras
ce haut responsable d'un État américain
est pour le moins étonnant.
Il y aura toujours des erreurs humaines
et des accidents qui peuvent se produire.
Notre rôle, c'est de minimiser
l'impact environnemental.
Pour ça, on recherche
les meilleures technologies disponibles,
pour empêcher autant
que possible les accidents et les erreurs.
Si je vous comprends bien, ça veut dire
que le coût d'un tel développement
engendre forcément
un impact sur l'environnement ?
Oui.
Un impact
que vous ne pouvez pas empêcher ?
Oui.
On ne peut pas totalement l'empêcher ?
On peut tout au plus le minimiser.
Inévitablement,
si vous installez 26 000 puits de pétrole
dans la nature,
vous allez forcément perturber
l'environnement pendant un certain temps.
Ça vaut vraiment le coup ?
Je suis sûr que oui.
Ce haut fonctionnaire l'admet lui-même,
malgré les dégâts sur l'environnement,
le pétrole de schiste est bien
trop vital pour que les États-Unis
acceptent de s'en passer.
En France, sous la pression
de l'opinion publique,
le gouvernement a décidé d'interdire
la fracturation hydraulique
pour les pétrole et gaz de schiste.
À ce jour, c'est le seul pays au monde
à avoir pris une telle décision.
Partout ailleurs sur la planète,
cette soif de nouveau pétrole
nous pousse
à aller chercher toujours plus loin.
Désormais, on creuse des puits en mer
à plus de trois kilomètres de profondeur,
au risque de provoquer
des catastrophes écologiques majeures,
comme ce fut le cas
dans le golfe du Mexique en 2010.
On bouleverse les paysages
pour extraire le pétrole
mélangé à la terre du Canada.
Pour y arriver, il faut raser
des milliers d'hectares de forêts
et ravager des régions entières.
Si le monde est prêt à accepter
toutes ces conséquences écologiques,
c'est parce que la demande d'or noir
ne cesse d'augmenter.
Chine, Inde, Brésil.
Les classes moyennes
des grands pays émergents
veulent consommer
autant de pétrole que nous.
De l'Orient à l'Occident,
Pour rouler, pour naviguer,
pour voler, pour construire,
nous le consommons tous de la même façon,
sans modération, comme si
c'était une ressource inépuisable.
Pire, nous le gaspillons.
Pour s'en rendre compte,
nous avons rendez-vous
au bout de cette petite route alsacienne
dans le petit village de Saasenheim.
C'est dans cette maison
que vivent Raphaël et sa famille.
Il y a neuf ans,
il a acheté cette grande bâtisse
de 160 mètres carrés.
Comme beaucoup
de maisons individuelles,
Raphaël est chauffé au fioul,
un dérivé du pétrole.
Cette cuve, c'est ma misère.
Il faut la remplir tous les ans
avec du fioul pour chauffer ma maison.
On l'a rempli en automne
et on en a consommé jusque-là.
J'espère que ça va suffire
pour faire l'eau chaude de l'été.
En six mois,
il a déjà consommé plus de la moitié.
Une facture de 1 600 euros par an
pour 2000 litres de fioul.
Raphaël est bien décidé
à faire baisser la note.
Pour cela,
il a fait appel à Christophe Beaune,
un spécialiste de l'isolation.
L'expert commence
par faire un tour de la maison
munie d'une caméra thermique
qui détecte les zones froides.
Par exemple, sur les doubles
vitrages de la cuisine.
Ah oui, c'est tout bleu.
On voit bien les courbes.
C'est vraiment de l'air froid
qui rentre par la fenêtre.
Les infiltrations d'air froid
autour des fenêtres
refroidissent toute la maison.
Pour compenser,
il faut consommer plus de fioul.
Il y a plus inquiétant encore,
ce sont les fuites d'air chaud
à travers les murs, car ils sont censés
être parfaitement étanches.
Là encore, l'expert va faire
une démonstration étonnante à Raphaël.
C'est le test de la porte soufflante.
Le technicien installe
un puissant ventilateur
à la place
de la porte d'entrée.
Il sert à chasser l'air vers l'extérieur.
Puis pour visualiser
les fuites d'air chaud,
il va enfumer toute la maison
avec une machine de boite de nuit.
À l'extérieur, ambiance garantie.
Oui, ça fume.
Ça fume partout.
On dirait qu'il y a un problème
comme une passoire.
Cette fumée emprunte le même chemin
que le chauffage de Raphaël.
Ça sort comme
s'il n'y avait rien.
Nos maisons sont de vraies passoires
et c'est de cette façon que Raphaël,
comme des millions d'autres français,
gaspille sans le savoir
des centaines de litres de fioul
chaque année.
Du pétrole littéralement
jeté par les fenêtres.
Pourtant, cette ressource s'épuise,
nous le savons tous.
C'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle le pétrole
coûte de plus en plus cher.
Dans un tel contexte,
est-il possible de s'en passer ?
À moins de heures de Paris,
un pays est en passe d'y arriver.
Ce pays, c'est la Suède.
Nous arrivons à Stockholm,
une capitale de 800 000 habitants.
En plein centre ville, de grands lacs,
si propres que l'on peut s'y baigner.
Des kilomètres de pistes cyclables
parfaitement intégrées
dans le paysage urbain.
En quelques décennies,
Stockholm est devenue
la ville emblématique de l'écologie.
Comme nous,
les suédois n'ont pas de pétrole.
Pourtant, ils mettent tout en œuvre
pour se passer d'or noir
dans leur vie quotidienne.
Voici le cadre de vie de Jessica,
une jeune mère de famille.
À première vue, ces immeubles
ne semblent pas très luxueux.
Pourtant, Jessica habite
dans un quartier résidentiel,
le plus écolo de Stockholm.
Ici, tout a été pensé
pour se passer de pétrole au quotidien.
Plus fort encore,
chacun produit tous les jours
de l'énergie
pour lui-même et ses voisins.
Nous allons nous en rendre compte
dans l'appartement
de Jessica et sa famille.
Dehors il fait 12 degrés,
à l'intérieur il fait 24 degrés,
les radiateurs sont à l'arrêt.
Comment on se sent
dans un appartement suédois
quand il fait aussi froid dehors.
On ne se rend même pas compte
qu'il fait froid dehors.
C'est ça qui est bien ici.
Dans l'un des pays
les plus froids d'Europe,
le chauffage n'existe
pratiquement pas chez Jessica
grâce à quelques astuces toutes simples.
Cela commence par les fenêtres.
De vraies murailles
pour empêcher la chaleur de s'échapper.
Ici, l'air frais ne rentre pas.
Il est stoppé net
par cette première fenêtre.
Derrière, un double vitrage
très performant
empêche la chaleur de sortir.
Entre les deux, une couche d'air
qui isole parfaitement
l'appartement de l'extérieur.
Du coup, Jessica n'utilise pratiquement
jamais son chauffage, même en hiver.
On ne chauffe presque pas.
Dans certaines pièces, on n'a pas utilisé
les radiateurs de l'hiver,
alors que cet hiver,
il a souvent fait -25 degrés.
Pour faire marcher ses radiateurs,
le plus incroyable,
c'est que c'est Jessica
elle même qui produit
la matière première pour se chauffer.
Ça se passe en cuisine lorsqu'elle prépare
les repas de la famille.
Sous son évier se trouvent les poubelles.
Elles semblent ordinaires, mais pour elle,
elles sont très précieuses.
C'est le plus sale.
Vous avez le reste des déchets
comme les couches.
Par exemple,
l'emballage de ma glace d'hier soir.
Cette poubelle
dans ce sac en plastique rose
contient tout ce qui n'est pas recyclable,
a priori des déchets inutiles.
Pourtant les suédois
ont réussi à les transformer
en un gisement d'énergie.
Pour le comprendre, il faut suivre Jessica
au pied de son immeuble.
Dans ce quartier, chaque bâtiment
est équipé de ces drôles de trappes
en forme de coffre-fort.
C'est ici que les habitants
viennent déposer leurs ordures.
Il y a une trappe
pour chaque type de déchets.
Là, par exemple,
c'est pour les déchets organiques
qui serviront de compost.
Celle-ci,
c'est pour y déposer les déchets
avec lesquels on va produire de l'énergie
qui remplace le pétrole.
Ça, c'est la trappe à ordures.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Les ordures comme les couches
et les déchets non recyclables.
Les déchets qui ne servent à rien ?
-Oui.
Jessica vient d'envoyer sa poubelle
dans un gigantesque réseau souterrain
de tuyaux collecteurs d'ordures.
Les déchets passent
par une cuve de stockage,
ils sont ensuite aspirés par un camion
qui se trouve de l'autre côté du quartier.
Ensuite, ce camion va acheminer
les poubelles de Jessica
et de tous les habitants
en périphérie de la ville,
jusque dans cette usine.
À partir de là, les 800 tonnes d'ordures
collectées chaque jour dans la capitale
finissent ici où
elles vont être transformées en énergie.
Nils, le responsable des déchets
à la mairie de Stockholm y veille.
Voilà ce qui se passe.
24 heures sur 24,
une pince métallique géante
s'empare des déchets et les dépose
dans un immense incinérateur.
Une installation
dont Nils est très fier.
À l'intérieur,
il fait entre 900 et 1000 degrés.
1000 degrés ?
-Oui.
La chaleur produite par ce four géant
sert ensuite à chauffer de l'eau
contenue dans ces gros tuyaux.
Lorsqu'elle sort de l'usine,
elle atteint les 100 degrés.
C'est cette eau
qui est envoyée dans toute la ville.
Elle arrive au pied des immeubles,
dans des chaufferies comme celles-ci.
De là, elle monte dans les radiateurs
de l'appartement de Jessica, par exemple.
Comme elle, 80 % des habitants
de Stockholm sont chauffés
avec l'énergie issue des poubelles.
Ainsi, en utilisant
les déchets à la place du pétrole,
cela permet d'économiser
150 000 tonnes d'or noir chaque année.
Pour les Suédois,
se chauffer sans pétrole
est devenu une obsession,
car utiliser les poubelles,
c'est une grosse source d'économie.
D'abord, les prix du pétrole
deviennent exorbitants.
Nous n'avons pas de pétrole
et il faudrait en apporter.
Les prix ne cessent de grimper.
Exactement.
Si vous voulez,
en utilisant d'autres sources
d'énergies alternatives
comme des poubelles,
c'est plus intéressant
et en plus ça pollue moins.
Cette recherche constante
d'énergies alternatives
répond à une prise de conscience,
un choix qu'ont fait les suédois
il y a 40 ans à cause
d'un événement qui les a traumatisé.
Nous sommes
en 1973 au Moyen-Orient.
C'est un coup de tonnerre.
Les principaux pays producteurs de pétrole
décident d'augmenter soudainement
les prix du brut.
En trois mois,
le prix du baril est multiplié par cinq.
C'est le début
du premier choc pétrolier.
Il impacte tous les pays occidentaux,
mais seuls les suédois
décident de tout mettre en œuvre
pour se passer
le plus possible de pétrole.
À partir de ce moment-là,
ils vont développer massivement
les énergies alternatives.
En 1973, c'était très difficile
d'être livré en pétrole.
Le pétrole était hors de prix
et on voulait
en importer le moins possible.
Certaines catastrophes servent à avancer.
En Suède, à ce jour, 45 % de la population
se chauffe grâce aux déchets.
En France, ce système existe aussi,
mais il ne concerne pour l'instant
que 2 % des français.
Pour se passer de pétrole au quotidien,
il y a un autre domaine
où la Suède va encore beaucoup plus loin
que la France, c'est celui des transports.
Pour faire marcher les voitures,
une source d'énergie inimaginable
est apparue récemment dans le pays.
Pour trouver cette énergie,
pas besoin de creuser en profondeur.
Ce sont les habitants
eux-mêmes qui la fabriquent naturellement.
Ce procédé révolutionnaire prend sa source
dans un rituel quotidien très banal.
Quand la petite fille de Jessica
prend son bain,
elle ne se doute pas
qu'elle va rendre service
à des milliers de suédois,
car dans cette eau,
il y a une énergie insoupçonnée.
Avec un geste aussi simple
que de vider la baignoire,
Andreas et tous ses voisins produisent,
sans même y penser, un nouveau carburant.
Comme en France,
les eaux usées empreintes
d'abord le chemin des égouts.
Elles sont canalisées
jusque sous cette colline.
Dans une usine souterraine
aux allures d'abri anti-atomique.
42 kilomètres de galeries
que l'ingénieur Larse Marlou
connaît comme sa poche.
C'est par là ?
-Oui.
C'est immense.
C'est dans ce tunnel
qu'aboutit toute la matière première
qui va servir
à fabriquer du carburant.
Bizarrement, nous ne sentons pas
de mauvaises odeurs.
Pourtant cette eau
a une origine peu glorieuse.
C'est l'eau
de nos chasses d'eau.
Cette eau a été
dans les toilettes de quelqu'un.
C'est l'eau des toilettes ici.
Eh oui.
C'est pourtant cette eau dégoûtante
qui a inspiré à Larse
un projet incroyable.
Il y a 25 ans, il a eu l'idée
d'utiliser cette matière organique
repoussante dont personne ne voulait,
car il a découvert
qu'elle recelait
un fort pouvoir énergétique.
C'est plutôt une bonne chose
de voir qu'un problème de déchets
peut se transformer en solution,
qu'on peut en faire
une vraie source d'énergie.
Pour libérer cette énergie,
les eaux dégoûtantes des toilettes
vont être séparées.
Ce sont les excréments
que cet ingénieur va utiliser.
Partout en Europe,
ces boues sont un casse-tête
qui coûtent très chères à traiter.
Larse a trouvé le moyen
de les transformer en carburant.
Pour cela, il les envoie
dans de grandes cuves
enterrées dans la roche.
On les appelle des digesteurs,
des estomacs géants chauffés à 37 degrés.
Dans ces digesteurs on trouve
des millions de micro-organismes voraces
qui raffolent de ces boues.
Elles vont leur servir de nourriture
et en les digérant,
ils rejettent un gaz précieux,
le méthane.
Il devient alors
ce qu'on appelle le biogaz,
un carburant propre.
18 000 mètres cube de gaz
sont ainsi récupérés,
concentrés et envoyés
chaque jour sur le réseau.
Ce carburant va être
aussitôt utilisé juste à côté d'ici,
dans la station-service
des bus de Stockholm.
Ce jour-là, ce chauffeur de bus
vient faire son plein habituel
avec une drôle de pompe.
Ça ne fait que sept ans
que ce carburant est en circulation,
déjà 10 % des bus de la ville
roulent avec du biogaz.
Nos eaux usées offrent ainsi
un carburant potentiellement disponible
dans toutes les grandes villes du monde,
même chez nous en France.
On peut produire ce carburant
n'importe où ?
Bien sûr, oui.
Le biogaz est produit localement
et il y en aura toujours.
Aussi longtemps qu'on ira aux toilettes
et qu'on se nourrira,
on aura la maîtrise de cette ressource.
C'est vraiment l'énergie du futur.
En Suède, 30 000 véhicules
roulent déjà au biogaz.
Il faut dire que toutes les voitures
qui roulent avec du pétrole
sont lourdement taxées,
jusqu'à 1 500 euros par an.
En choisissant un véhicule
avec un carburant vert,
il n'y a pas de taxe.
C'est ce qui a décidé Holof,
chauffeur de taxi depuis 45 ans,
à troquer son vieux taxi au diesel
contre une voiture au biogaz.
Quand ces voitures ont été lancées,
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé ?
Au début,
j'étais assez sceptique,
maintenant je pense
que ça va vraiment dans le bon sens.
À cause de l'environnement
et des économies ?
Oui, à cause des économies réalisées.
Ce taxi émet 20 fois
moins de particules polluantes
dans l'atmosphère.
Au moment de faire le plein,
il y a encore une autre bonne nouvelle.
Chaque litre pompé lui coûte
10 % moins cher que de l'essence.
Quand Holof démarre...
Vous pouvez me montrer ?
Oui, c'est juste ici.
Il n'y a aucune fumée d'échappement.
Il est là le pot ?
Vous pouvez accélérer ?
C'est incroyable.
Ça ne sent pas les poubelles.
En 20 ans, Stockholm a réussi
à diminuer de 25 %
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
C'est la seule capitale européenne
qui soit parvenue à un tel résultat.
Elle fait figure d'exemple.
Rouler autrement, rouler différemment
en se passant d'essence,
est devenu une priorité.
De New-York à Moscou,
de Rio à Bombay,
partout sur la planète,
le nombre de voitures explose.
Il y a déjà plus d'un milliard
de véhicules en circulation dans le monde.
On en prévoit
le double d'ici 30 ans.
Rien qu'à Pékin, il se vend
chaque jour plus de 2000 voitures.
À ce rythme, nul doute
que l'or noir ne suffira bientôt plus
à faire rouler tout le monde.
Face à cette consommation effrénée,
on cherche par tous les moyens
des alternatives au pétrole.
On a lancé la fabrication
de biocarburant avec des plantes.
Du maïs, de la canne à sucre,
de la betterave et bien d'autres végétaux.
Le problème, c'est qu'on a besoin
de ces terres
pour produire notre nourriture
et que les étendues cultivables
seraient de toute façon insuffisantes
pour fabriquer
tout le carburant nécessaire.
Aujourd'hui, les constructeurs auto
pensent avoir trouvé la solution,
une voiture
qui roule sans pétrole.
Sur la Côte d'Azur,
Les habitants de Nice
peuvent désormais l'utiliser.
Philippe a choisi de rouler
dans ce nouveau véhicule.
Ça accélère bien.
C'est totalement silencieux.
Ça se comporte
comme une voiture normale.
Il nous donne ses impressions
parce que cette voiture
ne marche pas à l'essence,
mais à l'électricité.
Chaque fois qu'il stationne,
il en profite
pour faire le plein d'énergie.
Voilà à quoi ressembleront
les stations-service du futur.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
La prise de rechargement.
On a juste
à la brancher à la voiture
comme on ferait
le plein de sa voiture à essence.
Pour recharger, il faut brancher
cette prise un peu curieuse
des véhicules électriques aujourd'hui,
il n'y en a que 8000
qui roulent en France.
D'ores et déjà,
la plupart des constructeurs mondiaux
se sont lancés
dans cette nouvelle bataille
pour le véhicule de demain.
La voiture électrique,
c'est la star attendue
dans le monde entier.
Il suffit de se balader
dans les grands salons de l'auto
pour s'en rendre compte.
De Paris à Pékin,
elle est exhibée sur tous les podiums.
Tantôt voiture de sports,
tantôt citadine,
version berline
ou même voiture de luxe.
Tout le monde l'annonce comme
le véhicule des 20 prochaines années.
Pour faire en sorte
que nous l'adoption,
il va falloir régler
un petit problème.
Dans cette usine du nord de la France,
un constructeur a lancé
la production en série
des premières voitures électriques.
Sur la chaîne en apparence,
il n'y a aucune différence.
Ce qui change
se trouve bien caché à l'intérieur.
C'est ce gros bloc de 150 kilos,
la batterie électrique.
C'est ce qui remplace
le réservoir à essence.
Elle permet de stocker l'électricité
pour rouler.
L'enjeu pour les constructeurs,
c'est d'avoir une batterie capable
de stocker le plus d'énergie possible
pour rouler le plus longtemps possible.
Pour cela, il faut utiliser
une ressource naturelle indispensable.
Sans elle, l'avenir
de la voiture électrique est compromis.
Cette matière première,
c'est le lithium,
un métal ultra léger
qui flotte sur l'eau.
Un métal tout mou
qui se coupe comme du beurre.
Pour faire rouler une voiture électrique,
il en faut énormément,
en moyenne 15 kilos par batterie.
Voilà pourquoi ce métal
va devenir si stratégique.
Le problème, c'est que cette matière
est loin d'être facilement accessible.
L'extraire de la Terre
n'est pas sans conséquences
sur notre environnement.
C'est ce que nous allons découvrir
au cours de notre enquête.
Nous partons là où le lithium
est convoité par les constructeurs
du monde entier.
En Amérique latine,
à cheval sur trois pays :
Le Chili,
l'Argentine et la Bolivie.
Dans une zone
qu'on appelle le triangle du lithium.
80 % du minerai le plus pur,
celui qui est utilisé pour nos voitures,
est concentré dans cette zone.
Un eldorado où se joue
notre énergie de demain.
À 12 heures de vol de la France,
le long de la Cordillère des Andes,
au nord du Chili,
nous atterrissons dans le désert
le plus sec au monde.
Le désert d'Atacama.
On se croirait
sur une autre planète.
À 2500 mètres d'altitude,
à un territoire de tous les extrêmes.
Température de -5 degrés la nuit
et de +30 degrés le jour.
Au milieu de ces paysages grandioses,
des usines à ciel ouvert.
C'est ici que l'on produit
la majorité du lithium mondial.
Si nous sommes venus jusque
dans cette région du bout du monde,
c'est que nous voulons comprendre
dans quelles conditions
est extrait ce lithium.
Bonjour.
-Oui, bonjour.
Comment allez-vous ?
Nous avons rendez-vous
avec Eduardo Morales,
un ingénieur chilien.
Il est venu explorer la zone
il y a 30 ans.
Depuis, il dirige l'une des plus grosses
usines de production au monde.
Sur la route vers le site,
une vision nous saisit.
En face de nous, une chaîne de montagnes
très impressionnante, des volcans.
Tu vois, là, autour de nous,
il y a une vingtaine de volcans.
Il y en a qui montent à jusqu'à
5000 ou 6000 mètres d'altitude.
Ils sont dangereux.
Beaucoup sont encore actifs,
il faut les surveiller en permanence.
Incroyable !
C'est d'une beauté hallucinante.
Ces volcans sont à l'origine
d'un phénomène naturel
commencé il y a des millions d'années.
Un phénomène qu'Eduardo Morales
connaît sur le bout des doigts.
Tu vois la neige
là haut sur les volcans ?
Elle fond en été et toute cette eau
va descendre des montagnes
en entraînant avec elle des sels minéraux
qui vont se retrouver sous ce désert.
L'eau s'écoule du volcan et elle arrive
ici avec plein de sels minéraux ?
Oui, c'est exactement ça.
Ce désert de sel,
c'est ce qu'on appelle ici un salar.
Il paraît tout sec à la surface.
En réalité, il est gorgé
d'eau en sous-sol,
une eau riche en sels minéraux
comme du lithium.
C'est ce trésor
qu'Eduardo convoite.
Il affleure parfois
à moins d'un mètre.
Là dedans, il y a du lithium
et tout un tas d'autres éléments,
du sodium, du calcium,
du sulfate, du magnésium.
Dans cette eau ?
-Oui, dans cette eau.
Il y a les batteries
des voitures de demain.
Oui, c'est ça.
En quelque sorte,
les voitures de demain.
Juste ici.
-Oui.
Dans cette eau gorgée de lithium,
Il y a la matière première
indispensable à nos voitures électriques.
Pour l'obtenir, il va falloir l'extraire
hors de cette eau souterraine.
C'est la mission d'Eduardo.
Pour cela, il a créé une usine
à ciel ouvert, en plein désert.
Vu d'en haut,
voilà à quoi cela ressemble.
À perte de vue sur le salar,
des alignements
de piscines géantes bleues,
turquoises ou vertes.
Les couleurs semblent surnaturelles.
Elles sont le résultat d'un processus
qui s'étale sur deux ans
pour en sortir au final, le lithium.
Au départ, comme pour le pétrole,
tout commence par une histoire de puits.
Voilà, c'est mieux.
Protégé du soleil par une cagoule,
c'est Pablo qui s'en occupe.
Dites-moi, ça sert
à quoi cet engin ?
Ça permet de descendre
à 120 mètres de profondeur.
Ce qu'on fait, c'est qu'on puise
cette eau pleine de lithium
et on va la verser
dans une grande piscine juste à côté.
C'est à partir de là
que va commencer le processus.
Toute l'eau avec le lithium
va passer par ce gros tuyau, c'est ça ?
Oui, c'est ça.
Un système qui permet de pomper
jusqu'à 200 000 litres par heure,
de quoi remplir
une première piscine géante.
À ce stade, le lithium est encore mélangé
à d'autres sels minéraux.
Pour les séparer,
c'est une énergie naturelle qui va agir.
Le soleil.
Il fait s'évaporer petit à petit l'eau
pour ne garder que les sels.
D'abord du sel de cuisine ou bien du sel
qui sert d'engrais pour la terre.
Ainsi de suite, cette eau
va passer de piscine en piscine
pour aboutir à un dernier bassin,
celui qui contient le fameux lithium.
C'est du 44 ?
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est pour aller dans le bassin ?
Là-bas.
On peut y aller ?
Pas de problème, suivez-moi.
Pour pénétrer dans l'ultime bassin,
mieux vaut s'équiper.
Au choix, on peut enfiler des bottes
ou une combinaison.
Enfin de quoi éviter
de s'enfoncer dans la vase.
Attention, c'est collant.
On ne va pas y arriver.
Vous êtes sûr
qu'on peut marcher dedans ?
Oui, c'est bon.
Le lithium est encore mélangé
à du magnésium
qui lui donne cette couleur vert fluo
et une consistance un peu particulière.
C'est très visqueux.
Oui, visqueux comme de l'huile.
À l'issue de tout ce parcours,
le lithium n'est pourtant pas encore pur,
mais il a déjà beaucoup de valeur.
Aujourd'hui, la demande
pour cette eau augmente beaucoup ?
Oui, cette demande
augmente très, très fort.
Pour les batteries au lithium,
pour la voiture électrique.
On peut dire que vous êtes chanceux.
Disons qu'on a de la chance
d'être avec le bon produit
au bon endroit
et au bon moment.
Dans les cinq ans à venir,
Eduardo prévoit même
de doubler la production de lithium.
Pour obtenir la matière
qui va équiper nos voitures,
ce concentré va devoir
partir en camions citernes
pour être traité ailleurs.
Ici, il manque une ressource essentielle,
de l'eau douce.
C'est dans cette usine,
à 300 kilomètres de là,
que l'on va transformer le lithium
en une substance
qu'il faut laver avec de l'eau,
des millions de litres d'eau douce.
Une eau indispensable pour obtenir
une poudre de la qualité la plus rare,
celle qui sert de base
aux batteries électriques du monde entier.
Prélever de l'eau des montagnes
n'est pas neutre ici.
Le désert d'Atacama manque d'eau douce.
Sur cette question,
Eduardo relativise l'impact
de son activité.
C'est vrai, il faut laver le lithium
avec une eau très pure,
si elle n'est pas très pure,
elle va laisser des impuretés
dans le produit
et il sera invendable.
Par exemple,
pour produire un kilo de lithium
ou de poudre de lithium, vous avez besoin
de combien de litres d'eau pure ?
D'eau pure,
on va dire un pour un.
Un litre pour un kilo.
Un litre d'eau
pour un kilo de lithium.
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est pas beaucoup d'eau,
c'est une faible consommation.
Quand même, c'est de l'eau pure.
Il n'y en a pas beaucoup ici
et les populations en ont besoin.
C'est vrai.
Le problème,
c'est que dans la région,
il y a déjà d'autres activités minières
qui consomment d'énormes quantités d'eau,
surtout le cuivre.
Le boom de la demande en lithium
ne va pas arranger les choses.
Selon un rapport officiel
d'une commission gouvernementale,
l'explosion de l'activité minière
va entraîner un déficit extrême d'eau
d'ici 2025 qui obligera à importer
massivement de l'eau d'autres régions.
Des tensions sur l'eau,
mais aussi des répercussions
sur la faune locale,
comme ces flamants roses
qui quittent peu à peu la région.
L'impact écologique des activités minières
se fait de plus en plus sentir.
Conséquence, l'exploitation du lithium,
est loin de faire l'unanimité
dans cette partie du monde.
Certains ont même décidé de faire barrage
à ceux qui veulent exploiter
cette matière première,
si vitale pour nos voitures du futur.
Nous partons à la rencontre
de ces opposants.
Direction l'Argentine, le pays voisin.
Sept heures de bus à travers
la Cordillère des Andes,
4000 mètres d'altitude.
Au milieu de cette région,
voici la cause d'une discorde
qui risque
de se révéler explosive.
La région de Salinas Grande
au nord du pays.
Ici, se trouvent des salar gorgés
de lithium qui sont l'enjeu
d'une véritable bataille.
Un conflit qui mêle intérêts économiques
et enjeux écologiques majeurs.
En 2010, l'État argentin a accordé
des permis d'exploration à des sociétés
dont certaines sont associées
à des fabricants d'automobiles
comme Toyota ou Bolloré.
Sur Salinas Grande,
un territoire immense et isolé,
la plupart des 5000 habitants
dispersés aux alentours
ne sont pas du tout d'accord.
Le bus local nous arrête
à quelques kilomètres du salar.
Nous avons rendez-vous à Agua Blanca,
un petit village de 180 habitants.
Ici, vivent des indiens,
des hauts plateaux depuis des générations.
Aujourd'hui, les villageois se rendent
à une réunion qui les mobilise tous.
Ils ont été invités par une avocate,
Alicia, venue spécialement
de la grande ville
à cinq heures de route.
Dis-lui de m'apporter les papiers,
je vais regarder ça.
Pour défendre leurs intérêts
face au lithium,
l'avocate veut rassembler
le plus d'indiens possible.
Selon elle, plus ils seront nombreux,
plus ils auront de poids dans leur combat.
Vous devez affirmer les droits historiques
que vous avez sur vos terres.
Demain, si une compagnie minière
vient vous dire, on va explorer,
la réponse, c'est non.
Une minorité d'indiens
contre des compagnies et l'État argentin.
A priori,
le combat est perdu d'avance.
Pourtant, il va falloir compter avec eux.
Les permis d'exploration de lithium
se trouvent précisément
sur les terres qu'ils occupent.
Ils n'ont pas été consultés
à l'avance comme cela aurait dû l'être.
Rien ne peut se faire sur ces terres
sans leur accord.
C'est ce que stipule
la Constitution argentine.
C'est donc cette faille juridique
qu'Alicia et les indiens vont exploiter.
Ils vont attaquer l'État argentin
devant la Cour suprême
pour empêcher l'exploitation du lithium
tant qu'ils n'auront pas donné leur avis.
Si on est tous d'accord là-dessus,
on va mener une action devant le tribunal.
Que ce soit bien clair,
on sait que c'est une lutte très inégale.
On va devoir se battre
contre les entreprises
les plus puissantes du monde
et contre le gouvernement.
Tous ensemble, on peut y arriver,
même si ça va être très difficile.
Quelle que soit l'issue du procès,
il y a dans l'assemblée
de farouches opposants au lithium,
des habitants déterminés
à aller jusqu'au bout.
Comme Ehoulalio par exemple.
Il habite à 20 minutes
du centre du village à pied.
Un paysan qui a toujours vécu là.
Ce qui est à moi,
s'étend à quatre kilomètres par là,
par là bas,
ça va à plus de 30 kilomètres.
À 30 kilomètres ?
Oui, au moins.
Ici, on est chez nous et pour toujours
ce sera notre territoire.
Tu vas te battre ?
-Oui, jusqu'au bout.
S'ils entrent ici, c'est mon combat,
je mourrai pour ma terre.
S'il faut mourir en se battant,
je suis prêt.
Je me battrai
jusqu'à la fin de ma vie.
Si Ehoulalio est aussi déterminé,
c'est qu'il craint un impact direct
sur son environnement.
Sur ses terres, il élève des lamas
et des moutons.
Pour ses bêtes et sa famille,
la seule eau potable
vient du puits de la ferme.
Un point d'eau vital et déjà menacé
par une sécheresse
qui s'aggrave d'année en année.
Avant je veux puiser à six mètres
et maintenant à neuf.
Il n'y a plus beaucoup d'eau ici ?
Non, c'est tout sec.
C'est pour ça que je ne veux pas
d'usines de lithium ici.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
Les mines vont puiser l'eau
qu'il y a en dessous.
Elles utilisent beaucoup d'eau.
On vivait comme ça
depuis des milliers d'années.
Avec le lithium,
ils vont tout ravager en 10 ou 50 ans.
Nous, ce qu'on veut,
c'est la vie, pas la mort.
Entre les indiens et l'État argentin
qui souhaite le développement du lithium,
qui l'emportera ?
Il est encore trop tôt pour le dire,
mais une chose est sûre,
cette contestation a pour l'instant
retardé l'exploitation du lithium
dans le Salinas Grande.
L'accès au lithium n'est pas
une mince affaire
pour les constructeurs automobiles
du monde entier.
D'autant que cette matière première,
importante pour l'avenir de nos voitures,
est devenue un enjeu qui va
bien au-delà des problèmes écologiques.
Désormais, cette ressource
est une arme politique et économique
que certains ici comptent bien utiliser.
À 500 kilomètres au nord,
nous arrivons à la frontière bolivienne.
La première image qui nous frappe,
c'est une colonne de fourmis humaines.
Des centaines de gens qui vont et viennent
en transportant des paquets à même le dos.
Les signes d'une économie
de la débrouille et de la survie.
Il faut dire que la Bolivie
est un pays à part sur le continent,
ça se voit dès la douane.
Nous nous trouvons
dans l'un des derniers États
à se réclamer de la révolution
marxiste et anticapitaliste.
À sa tête, un ancien syndicaliste,
le président Evo Morales.
Dans les rues,
une dure réalité se ressent partout.
La Bolivie est le pays le plus pauvre
du continent américain.
Près d'un habitant sur deux
gagne moins de 2 euros par jour.
Pourtant tout près d'ici,
se trouve une richesse prodigieuse,
d'une beauté incroyable,
le salar d'Uyuni.
Une infinité blanche.
Le relief se perd à l'horizon.
Impossible d'en voir les limites.
Ce désert de pur sel blanc
est le plus vaste du monde.
Avec 100 kilomètres sur 150,
il fait la taille de l'Île-de-France.
Sous cette immense couche de sel,
la moitié des réserves mondiales
du plus pur des lithium.
De quoi changer la donne mondiale.
Le lithium pourrait devenir
pour la Bolivie
ce que le pétrole est aujourd'hui
pour l'Arabie Saoudite,
une manne colossale
et un instrument de pouvoir planétaire.
Actuellement, ce gisement
n'est pas encore exploité.
Pourtant le monde entier le convoite.
Chinois, Japonais,
Coréens ou même Français,
des groupes de tout pays
veulent y accéder.
Pour l'instant,
aucun n'a eu de concession
car tout dépend d'une décision
qui va se prendre
au plus haut niveau de l'État.
Pour savoir si un jour nous pourrons
profiter du lithium bolivien,
nous avons
un dernier trajet à faire,
sept heures de train
pour arriver à La Paz.
Deux millions d'habitants entassés
entre 3500 et 4000 mètres d'altitude.
C'est dans la capitale politique du pays
que nous avons rendez-vous
avec l'homme le plus puissant
après le président Evo Morales,
le ministre des Mines.
C'est ici que se joue l'avenir
du plus gros gisement mondial.
Avec l'or, l'argent,
l'étain et demain le lithium,
les minerais sont
le poumon économique du pays.
Désolé, le ministre va avoir du retard.
Il faut attendre un peu.
Pendant notre attente,
nous remarquons une affiche au mur
qui nous intrigue.
On dirait de Che Guevara.
Dès le bureau des fonctionnaires,
le ton est donné.
Ici, la révolution est toujours en cours.
Bonjour.
Le Che, c'est un modèle pour l'État ?
Oui, comme lui,
on se bat pour la justice dans notre pays.
Che Guevara,
le héros de la révolution cubaine
avec Fidel Castro dans les années 60.
Chez nous, une icône du passé,
ici, un modèle politique
toujours d'actualité.
Selon vous, qu'est-ce le Che
penserait du fait qu'on exploite
le lithium par exemple ?
Je crois qu'il dirait qu'il faut d'abord
préserver nos ressources naturelles.
Pour lui, on ne doit pas
sacrifier nos ressources
pour qu'elles profitent
à des entreprises capitalistes étrangères.
Elles doivent d'abord profiter
au peuple bolivien et à personne d'autre.
La méfiance envers
les entreprises étrangères
est très marquées dans ce pays.
Elle pèse dans
toutes ses décisions stratégiques.
Nous allons nous en rendre compte
avec José Pimentel,
le ministre des Mines.
Avec le président,
il détient les clés du lithium.
Sur cette carte, on voit les richesses
de l'Amérique latine et celle de Bolivie.
C'est sûr, on a tout ce qu'il
faut pour fournir la planète.
En réserve, on a des millions
et des millions de tonnes de lithium.
Ces fabuleuses richesses
ont de quoi enrichir la Bolivie
et en faire une grande puissance
au XXIᵉ siècle.
Le ministre a une inquiétude
que les entreprises étrangères en abusent,
comme ce fut
le cas ici autrefois.
Pendant des siècles,
des mineurs, des paysans,
des indigènes ont été tués.
Voilà ce que nous a laissé
l'exploitation impérialiste
dans notre pays.
Ça, ce sont les plaies
encore à vif de notre continent.
Un traumatisme collectif
pour les boliviens
qui remonte à très loin.
En 1538, les conquistadors
envahissent leur pays
et font main basse
sur les mines d'argent de Bolivie.
Pendant 300 ans,
ils vont réduire les indiens en esclavage.
Bilan de cette invasion,
8 millions de morts.
Aujourd'hui, les Boliviens
n'ont toujours pas oublié et depuis,
la crainte des étrangers reste vive.
Ce serait quoi le risque ?
D'être sous domination étrangère
à cause du lithium,
comme ce fut le cas autrefois
avec les mines d'argent ?
Ce serait désastreux pour nous.
Au contraire, notre défi,
c'est de ne plus jamais revivre ça,
et même de réussir à imposer
aux multinationales
de se comporter en associé,
pas juste en patrons
qui gardent tous les bénéfices
pour eux et rien pour nous.
Deux siècles
après le pillage de ses richesses,
la Bolivie fixe ses règles du jeu.
Les entreprises
qui veulent décrocher un marché
vont devoir
se montrer convaincantes.
Du côté des français, par exemple,
le groupe de Vincent Bolloré.
L'industriel français
investit massivement dans l'électrique,
fabrication de voitures,
de batteries, service Autolib à Paris.
Il y a deux ans,
quand le Président Evo Morales
vient en France en visite d'État,
l'industriel lui propose un partenariat.
Pour le convaincre, il lui promet
de fabriquer les batteries en Bolivie.
Lors de la démonstration
de sa voiture électrique, Vincent Bolloré
montre à Evo Morales
quel pouvoir le président de la Bolivie
détient avec son lithium.
C'est vous qui contrôlez
la matière qui permet,
comme l'Arabie Saoudite,
pour le 21ᵉ et 22ᵉ siècle.
Deux ans plus tard,
rien n'est décidé.
Face à Bolloré,
il y a du monde sur les rangs,
la concurrence est féroce.
À La Paz, le ministre des Mines
en est conscient et compte en profiter
pour faire monter les enchères.
On n'a toujours pas pris de décision.
Les offres sont nombreuses.
Il n'y a pas que les français.
On négocie avec tout le monde
et naturellement,
nous choisirons la plus avantageuse
pour le peuple bolivien.
Quelle est la première
entreprise étrangère
la mieux placée pour venir ici ?
La Chine, la Corée, la Finlande,
la Suisse et il y en a d'autres.
Pourquoi pas l'Iran ?
Nous verrons bien en temps voulu
qui est le meilleur ami de la Bolivie.
Rien n'est gagné
pour tous ceux qui rêvent
d'exploiter rapidement
le lithium bolivien.
Si les grands fabricants de voitures
acceptent ces conditions,
les pays d'Amérique latine
seront peut-être cet eldorado
qui nous permettra de rouler
sans pétrole au XXIᵉ siècle.
C'est ici, sur les hauts plateaux andins
que se termine notre enquête.
Notre voyage aux quatre coins du monde
nous a permis de comprendre
que l'ère de l'après pétrole a commencé.
Dans 15 ans, les réserves actuelles
ne suffiront plus
à fournir toute la planète.
D'ici là, les prix ne vont cesser
de monter et la pollution d'augmenter.
Ce constat nous oblige
à agir au quotidien dès maintenant
pour économiser
cette précieuse ressource.
Nous pouvons par exemple choisir
de privilégier les transports en commun
ou les nouveaux moyens de déplacement
mis à disposition par les villes.
Des énergies de substitution
sont déjà à notre portée.
Comme l'Espagne,
une dizaine d'autres pays
se sont lancés dans la construction
de centrales solaires.
Dans le Sahara, un gigantesque
projet européen envisage
de capter les rayons du soleil
pour transporter cette énergie
jusqu'en Europe.
En France, les villes de Nanterre
et Levallois utilisent déjà
la chaleur des égouts
pour chauffer des bâtiments.
D'autres villes
vont bientôt suivre cet exemple.
Pour nous déplacer,
de nouvelles inventions
pourraient bientôt
révolutionner notre quotidien,
comme la voiture à hydrogène
qui ne rejette que de l'eau
et n'émet aucun polluant.
Ou les biocarburants
fabriqués avec des algues,
qui n'ont pas besoin
de terres cultivables.
En un siècle et demi,
le pétrole a changé le monde.
Il a permis d'accomplir
des révolutions technologiques
plus rapidement
que n'importe quelle autre découverte
dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes tous
face à un incroyable défi,
celui de se préparer à vivre autrement,
à vivre sans pétrole.